[Music]
it's that time of the month again sony
have unveiled the playstation plus
lineup for the month of november 2020.
this month we have three games spread
across ps5 and ps4
but those of you on ps5 remember there
are another 18 games you can download as
soon as you get your ps5 back home
but right now let's focus on the three
games for november which are available
from november the 3rd which is a tuesday
by the way
starting with the first ever ps plus
game on ps5
bug snacks it looks insane and it
sure is we play as an investigative
journalist who is sent to explore
snagtooth island
the home of legendary critters creatures
which are half
bug half food source our job is to
capture 100 species
and find out how the island's
inhabitants live among these things
here's a great thing to know right now
bug snacks is here on ps plus
for two months november and december
until january the 4th
2021 so if you're hoping for a ps5 for
christmas
then rest safe that you'll still have
time to grab this weird take on video
game collectibles on christmas day
it isn't all happy fun times though in
this game what the freak is that
in the sky i never knew i wanted to play
bug snacks
until it dropped on ps plus are you
gonna try it
i would love to know your thoughts game
number two this month and back to our
beloved ps4
middle earth shadow of war built to
resemble many mechanics from the early
assassin's creed games
but with a tolkien twist the lord of the
rings references come thick
and fast as we travel with talion again
through the events in between the hobbit
and the lord of the rings trilogy
released in 2017 to positive reviews
averaging around 7.5 out of 10. the huge
unique point for shadow of war is the
nemesis system
it's possible to place puppet uruks in
the enemy hierarchy
and watch them progress through the
ranks but they can't be trusted
so expect a knife in your back at some
point another great point is that the
randomly generated characters in this
nemesis system
have unique voice lines and
characteristics you play this game three
times you'll have completely different
characters every time
if you haven't played it before it holds
up well in 2020 and if you have
i think it's time to jump back in again
grab it from november the third
and finally game number three again for
the ps4 but again of course it can be
played on the ps5
too this is hollow knight void heart
edition
another 2017 game this time it's a 2d
metrovania type affair in which you'll
be backtracking to previous areas with
new found upgrades
to unlock more content and progression i
haven't played this one and looking over
the reviews
i am shooketh so many 10s and 9s scores
everywhere
the void heart edition includes four
enhancement dlcs named hidden dreams the
grim troop
lifeblood and godmaster which add to the
story greatly i'm told
so there we have it three games for the
month of november 2020
with another 18 for those on ps5 it's a
pretty good month i think
how would you rate the month especially
if you're not moving to ps5 what do you
think
i'll be stalking in the comments to see
what the community thinks i'm adam from
playstation grenade you're not here
you've already clicked off the video
that's okay i can handle it
see you next time
you